hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
throughout all things are possible
you're going to see lev chester
talking about morality and
most of his discussions of it are both
quite involved and
also what we could call genealogical
unmasking to some degree saying here's
what's really going on
with morality it looks like it's on the
up and up like it provides us with a
total basis
for doing all the things that we ought
to do but really
here's the function that's going on and
i want to say a few things right off the
bat before we start looking at some of
the
passages and putting together kind of a
composite picture
to begin with it's important to remember
that chestoff is essentially a second
generation existentialist
he is somebody who not only has studied
extensively
dostoyevsky and nietzsche both of whom
have a lot of thoughts
about the nature of morality and how
it's often not what it pretends to be
but who's actually written on them by
this point as well
and published works about them he's also
you know drawing on other
authors and he's somebody who knows the
history of philosophy
quite well so you'll see him talking
about kant for example
talking about plato aristotle hegel all
sorts of other figures
so he's he's using this sort of
panoramic picture of how morality
has been treated and we should point out
too
that you know the existentialists were
not the first to discover that morality
sometimes is actually a cover
for other things the second thing that
we need to keep in mind
is he's not going to provide us with a
definition of morality
he's not going to provide us with a
general theory of morality
that would be in in part besides the
point and that would be to accede to
some
moral demands of theorizers you might
say so if your temptation is to say to
shut up hey
you've got to tell me what you mean by
morality he would say no actually i
don't
there's no more requirement that i do
that nor is that a requirement of
intelligent people
exploring some some phenomena you know
that's
you imposing something in a bullying
kind of way to use another
term that he's going to use later on as
a matter of fact as it turns out
morality doesn't name just one single
thing
it names a number of different
coordinated things and again this is
similar to
what existentialists like nietzsche have
said about
matters like this so
what are we uh discussing here we're
looking at how people engage in
moralizing
we're looking what the moral lists say
we're looking at how people
apply rules of morality to each other
all sorts of other connected phenomena
and we can distinguish
some different themes we can talk about
morality as what he calls
utilitarian and we'll get into that in
just a moment
morality is what we could call
retributive and secretly
selfish we can also talk about morality
he talks about this a little bit less in
this book but morality is a sort of
class
distinction a way of of
showing that you're somebody important
and he also discusses morality in
relation to what he calls a fabric
of fear and here we get to what our
attitude might
or might be or ought to be in relation
to all these demands that are put on us
and this sort of capital m morality
that's constantly thrust on us and then
we also
have a really interesting passage where
he talks about
what might place things in a different
perspective
so when we're talking about morality as
utilitarian
he doesn't mean that everybody is
engaging in utilitarian moral theory
coming from jeremy bentham or john
stuart mill
as a matter of fact he's using it in a
very broad sense that people
were using it at the time to talk about
you know morality as being something
that has its origins
in what's good for society
writ large what's good for the social
group you might think if you're
somebody who reads 19th century
literature about somebody like herbert
spencer
who nobody really reads anymore but
who would have exactly the same sort of
idea it's it's the kind of people that
nietzsche was attacking in the genealogy
immoral as those english psychologists
who see in the notion of moral
obligations
and moral codes just what is to the
benefit of most people
and he talks about this
in noting
a a sort of interest in contemporary
philosophy
what he calls the normative theory which
has taken such hold in germany
and russia and he says that what's
really going
on with this normative theory is that it
amounts to this philosophical research
is not a search after truth
but a conspiracy among people who
dethrone truth
and exalt instead the all binding
norm so this is more than just ethics
in in the narrow sense this is like how
we conduct ourselves in general
everything should be you know normalized
everything should be following this all
binding norm universality
and so here's where he says something
really interesting the task is truly
ethical
morality always was and always will be
utilitarian and bullying its active
principle is
he who is not with us is against
us and so that is an interesting way to
think about
what people mean by morality it's a code
by which people
uh keep other people in line and there's
there's another
really interesting discussion that
crystallizes a lot of
other uh chapters where he's talking
about
you know the need to provide consistency
for
other people so in uh chapter
100 of part one he says
here we go it's clear to any impartial
observer
practically every person changes their
opinion ten times a day
nobody has ever doubted it was a that it
was a vice to be unstable in one's
opinions
three quarters of our education goes to
teaching us most carefully
to conceal within ourselves the
changeableness of our moods and
judgments
a person who cannot keep their word is
the last of people never to be trusted
likewise
a person with no firm convictions it's
impossible to work together with them we
want people who we
we know how they're going to to think
how they're going to behave what they're
going to say
even if they're scoundrels we want them
to be consistent scoundrels
we want to understand why the screwed
upness of their character
produces these sorts of effects here's
where he says something really
interesting
morality here is always making towards
utilitarian ends right
things that will be good for the
majority issues
the eternal principle thou shalt remain
true to thy convictions
people have to be what they are now this
see this goes beyond just like rules of
conduct
or ethical principles or anything like
that it has to do with the entirety
of a person's life and demeanor and
character and where they fit in
once they've established something
unless they've got a really good reason
to change it
they must stick with that because we
want them to
because that's how things ought to be
well this is all
morality this is all a way in which
society imposes its demands
on other people and he says in cultured
circles this commandment is considered
so
unimpeachable men are terrified even to
appear
inconstant in their own eyes they become
petrified
in their beliefs and no greater shame
can happen that they should be forced to
admit that they've altered in their
convictions right so that's an
interesting side of it as well
this is morality as utilitarian you know
we demand a sort of
constancy in in social life
we want to be able to rely on people
everyone should stay as we say
in their lane or if they're getting out
of their lane it's when there's
something that allows them to do so and
we give them permission for that
so that's a you might say neutral side
to morality it's going to stifle
innovation and creativity to some degree
and it's also going to
you know introduce fears for people of
appearing inconsistent
but it's not that big of a problem here
we
also with a second theme get to
something that's a bit more
problematic about morality which is
supposed to be for good right
chester says that morality also has its
roots
in retribution in revenge in
vengeance and so we look at section
34 he says moral
people are the most revengeful of
mankind they employ their morality
as the best and most subtle weapon of
vengeance and that might be you know
coming out of
nietzsche's mouth or out of the mouth of
one of dostoevsky's characters could it
not right so this is
uh you know it could also be coming from
various cynical
philosophers people who are talking
about morality all the time
who arrange the world through moral
categories
they're really about vengeance
they're really about doing something and
now he
he points out it gives an argument here
they're not satisfied with simply
despising and condemning their neighbor
themselves
they they're upset about something they
see somebody
you know watering their lawn during the
middle of a drought
that's a bad thing that you're doing
that is a bad thing right it
certainly goes against you know being a
good member of society but they take it
personally
that jerk look at them over there doing
that thing
you know in this case with some people
who are particularly prudish
and ascetic it might even be look at
those people over there having fun
i can't imagine what they're doing there
this is awful right people
do behave that way and there's all sorts
of rules that you can like apply to
people
and if the rules don't cover it you can
find a principle that covers it as well
there's no law against that but you're
still doing the wrong thing
now here's where it gets really
interesting and this is why
shestop says that they are the most
revengeful of humankind
they don't just want they don't just
want to condemn their neighbor
themselves
they want the condemnation as he says to
be universal
and supreme and there's two aspects to
this
universal and supreme supreme means it
overrides anything else there's no
excuse
there's no justifying exception in this
case and it's universal we want
everybody to condemn this person
everyone should say that this person is
bad so they want everyone else
to condemn that person that's one side
of it and they'll often get angry at you
if you don't condemn quickly enough or
don't condemn
in the right way or for the right
reasons but they also
want the offender's own conscience to be
against them
then only are they fully satisfied and
reassured
he says and now how often do you
actually get this
pretty rarely i mean you can get
compliance from people where they'll say
yes
yes i did the wrong thing i'm sorry for
doing it but in their heart of hearts
they're thinking
you friggin jerk you know calling me out
on this look at you you hypocrite
and you're not getting the result that
you want but morality in
in people like this is really looking to
to
crush the person as he said earlier it's
a kind of bullying right
um there's another really interesting
discussion i'm going to jump
right away to 64 where he says
moral indignation is only a refined form
of ancient vengeance
once anger spoke with daggers now words
will do
happy is the man who loving and
thirsting to chastise his offender
is appeased when the offense is punished
on account of the gratification it
offers to the passions
morality which has replaced bloody
chastisement will not easily
lose its charm right so
condemnation of people joining in on
saying these people are bad look at how
wrong they are
keeping a program upon them calling them
names
this is part of the moral impulse
according to chef stuff
it's a way of attaining um ancient
vengeance
it also has some other nice features to
it
uh nice in being a little bit facetious
there
and he discusses this in chapter 11 of
part two
which is entitled in defense of
righteousness
he says inexperienced and ingenious
people see in righteousness merely a
burden
which lofty people have assumed out of
respect for law
or some other high and inexplicable
reason but
a righteous person has not only duties
but
rights what does following the rules
you know being a moral person what does
that get you
you can say well i'm happy with my
conscience but it also
allows you to engage in this
condemnation
of other people he says when the law is
against him he has to compromise
but how rarely does the law desert him
he says no cruelty matters in him as
long as he does not infringe the
statutes
no he will actually ascribe his cruelty
as a merit to himself
because he acts out of no personal
considerations but in the name of sacred
justice and this can fit in perfectly
well you know morality can be
retributive
and and self-centered and a person can
lie to themselves
and everybody else and say oh no no no
it's not i don't want to hurt the other
person
i am hurting them of course but i just
want to make sure that justice is done
i'm speaking on behalf of society or
the victim or whoever else the principle
of the matter
requires that i do this this thing to
the other person
he says no matter what he may do once
he's sanctioned he sees in his actions
only merit merit merit
modesty forbids him to say too much but
if you're to let go
what a luxurious panjarik he must might
deliver
to himself and he says the nature of
virtue demands it a person must rejoice
in their morality
and ever keep it in mind after that
people declare it's hard to be righteous
whatever the other virtues may be
certainly righteousness has
its selfish side and
he's saying that that a lot of people
use morality essentially as a tool
to attain their own selfish and
vengeance driven
ends it's quite likely true if you
consult your own experience
you might find a little bit of that in
yourself or in others
a little bit later he talks about
morality as kind of a class
distinction thing he's got this uh
discussion
which is entitled no bless oblige and
what is noblesse obliged it's what the
upper classes were supposed to be doing
it means that if you actually have a
higher station
you're supposed to take care of those
below you and you do it kind of in your
own
way on your own time but you're supposed
to do it so like if you were in ancient
athens and you had a ton of money you
don't get to just keep all your ton of
money to yourself
you put on a choral performance or
a play or you buy a trireme for the city
and if you don't then people are gonna
be like that person
is not living up to their their duties
but you get to decide what you're going
to do with it maybe you
dedicate something to the temple you
know maybe you provide a common dinner
for everybody but you're supposed to do
something and so he says
the moment of obligation compulsion duty
and that moment described by kant is the
essential almost the only predicate of
moral concepts
serves chiefly to indicate kant was
modest in himself in
his attitude towards all whom he
addressed perceiving in all people being
subject to the ennobling effect of
morality morality could like
make us better when we're moral beings
we do things for other people without
expecting something in return
without using it as a tool of vengeance
right
he says noblesse oblige is a motto not
for the aristocracy which recognizes
in its privileges its own instant duties
but for the self-made
wealthy parvenus who pant for an
illustrious
title the nouveau riche as we call them
the people
who didn't grow up with a proverbial
silver spoon
in their mouth and knowing what their
their obligations are
they take on those obligations why well
he says they've been accustomed to
telling lies to playing
pultrune swindling and meanness and the
necessity for speaking the truth
impartially
bravely facing danger freely giving of
their fortunes
scares them beyond measure they're not
used to doing that sort of thing
they're not used to behaving in a noble
way
so he says it's necessary they should
repeat it to themselves they lie to
themselves
about why they ought to do this and then
to their children
in whose veins the lying sneaking blood
still runs
lest they forget you must not tell lies
you must be open magnanimous
and he says this is kind of silly but no
bless oblige
so sometimes morality can be something
that is not just being used as a tool
but it actually constrains
the person against themselves here's
where we get to another really
interesting
uh discussion he begins by talking about
the
old adage man is a wolf to man
hominy homo hominy lupus and he says
this is one of the most steadfast maxims
of eternal morality
we are worried about our neighbors doing
bad stuff to us and so one
reason why we have morality is to keep
them from doing anything to us and then
we
in turn say we're not going to do that
stuff either he says that that fear is
just
we are so poor so weak so easily ruined
and destroyed
how can we help being afraid and then he
says and yet behind danger and menace
there's usually hidden something
significant which merits our close
and sympathetic attention but fear's
eyes
are big we see danger danger early
and here's the real upshot he says we
build up a fabric of morality
inside which as in a fortress we sit out
of danger
all of our lives so we do it to
ourselves we moralize
ourselves because of our fear of the
neighbor and perhaps fear of what we
might do as well
and this constrains us this restricts us
the last thing that i wanted to bring up
in terms of this you know rather
uh let's call it skeptical view on
morality that that chest off is evincing
which might put things in perspective
he's not against
goodness he's not against ethics he's
not against you know doing the right
thing he's just saying that maybe
morality doesn't structure things
the way that we we think it should and
it allows too much openness
for people to use it and abuse it he
talks about what if
christ was going to show up today this
is in chapter
67 you might think about that
song what if god was one of us which
if i remember the way the verses go a
slob like one of us
shows up and we don't know that it's
it's god and there's a big surprise
he has a really interesting thing that
he says here he says the pharisee and
the parable
fulfilled all that religion demanded of
him he kept his fast pace paid his tithe
we're talking about the case where the
pharisee
is you know congratulating himself in
the temple for doing
all of the the requirements fulfilling
all the moral obligations
that were also religious obligations
meanwhile there's a tax collector tax
collectors are despised
because they're agents of the roman
empire and he's over there
and he's beating his breast and he's
saying have mercy on me lord a sinner
he's uh you know saying that he he's
actually screwed up
and then christ you know in the parable
says you know that guy was justified
the the person who you know condemned
himself
that one who thought that he was
righteous was not justified
and so when imagine that you're at the
time when this story is told
he says everybody thought that this guy
was righteous
including the pharisee himself the
judgment of christ
came as the greatest surprise to him
he had a clear conscience he did not
merely pretend
before others to be righteous he
believed in his own righteousness
suddenly he turns out to be guilty
awfully guilty
but if the conscience of a righteous
person does not help them to distinguish
between good and evil how is he to
avoid sin and then chester says
what does kant's moral law mean the law
which was consoling as the starry sky
you know if christ came again he might
condemn
the serene philosopher for his very
serenity the possibilities that we
have things wrong and that there could
be some sort of revelation that
we are fundamentally screwed up even
when we're
practicing morality we've gotten things
wrong
that could always happen what a surprise
that would be
how would we react to that would we go
out to greet it and say
this is really a shock i need to rethink
things or would we
persecute that person would we use
morality as a tool against them would we
say shut up
you can't change anything at this point
it's a good question isn't it
and so here's you know this is not the
only things that chester says about
morality there's there's more contained
in this work
there's more contained in his larger
corpus but these are some of the
main points about his views on morality
and how it impacts our lives and
connects up with philosophy
you